قال رئيس الامريكيه خلال كلمته في قمه
المناخ شرم الشيخ انه يعتذر عن انسحاب
بلاده من اتفاقيه بريس للمناخ واكد ان
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بمكافحه التغيير
المناخي وتوفير موارد لوقف الاحتباس
الحراري
يعتمد على طاقه نظيفه ليست فقط امر حتميا
بالنسبه لحاضرين ومستقبلنا ولكنها مسؤوليه
امام التاريخ الاعوام الثمانيه الماضيه
كانت الاكثر حراره منذ بدا قياس درجاتها
هنا في افريقيا التي يوجد بها عدد من
الدول التي تعد اكثر هشاشه امام التغير
المناخي وتعاني من انعدام الامن الغذائي
يستمر الجفاف منذ اربع سنوات في القرن
الافريقي ان الازمه المناخيه تهدد امن
البشريه الامن الاقتصادي والامن المناخي
والحياه على كوكب الارض برمتها اريد ان
اخبركم اليوم ان الولايات المتحده تجعل من
ازمه المناخ حاله طوارئ وتعبر عن عزمنها
على ضمان ان يكون مناخ كوكبنا انظف وامنه
لنا جميعا
هذا هو اجراء رئيس الامريكي جون فائدى
المحادثات مع رئيس المصريه عبد الفتاح
السيسي على اهم شي قمه المناخ في شرم
الشيخ
وصف بعض
الشريك الاستراتيجي والموثوق مشيرا الى
انه سيبحث اشتراكه في مجال الدفاع والجهود
المبذوله في منطقه الشرق الاوسط واقل
البيت الابيض ان بعيدا عربا ان تضامن
واشنطن مع القاهره في مواجهه التحديات
النجمه عن حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ودعمه
لحقوق مصر المائيه كما اكد انا اثار في
اجتماعه مع السيسي اهميه حقوق الانسان
واحترام الحريات الاساسيه من جانبه قرر
الرئيس المصري ان العلاقات بين مصر
والولايات المتحده استراتيجيه ولم تتغير